foreign affairs and international
development
honorable committee members excellencies
per racer and kovaliv it is my pleasure
to be with you today to provide
perspective on the matter at hand on
behalf of the european union
since the very first day of the
unprovoked illegal egregiously
unjustified military invasion of ukraine
by the russian federation
europe has been helping ukraine
economically financially with
humanitarian assistance diplomatically
politically and with the provision of
weapons through the european peace
facility
and we will continue to do so
in order to restrict the kremlin's means
to finance this disastrous war
the eu and its member states have also
adopted the largest sanctions package in
european union history we are closely
cooperating with our transatlantic and
international allies with canada being
one of our closest partners
we appreciate the timely and efficient
exchange of information as well as the
support that canada has been providing
to ukraine
we appreciate canada's investment in
european security and its commit
commitment to a rules-based
international
order
to cut revenue sources for russia from
its energy exports the eu is determined
to wean itself off russian energy all
together
to this end a decision was made to ban
90 of oil imports from russia by the end
of this year we have also adopted a ban
on all imports of call from russia the
export of specific refining technologies
as well as new investments in the
russian energy sector
the eu sanctions regime however does not
affect goods or technology linked to the
industrial transport of natural gas into
the european union
nor is north stream 1 subject to any eu
sanctions
in other words
nothing under the eu sanctions regime
would have prevented the
repatriation of the north stream 1
turbine
the european commission welcomed the
decision by canada to return a natural
gas pipeline turbine to germany after
its repair for use in the north stream 1
pipeline which has been transporting gas
to a number of european countries
with the return of this part one of the
excuses being used by russia for reduced
gas flows was removed such flows in the
short term help eu countries to stop hop
on supplies for the winter and are part
of a strategy of phasing out our
reliance on russian energy
russia is continuously using energy
supplies as a weapon against the eu and
its member states
we have adopted a number of measures to
prepare for possible further disruptions
of gas supplies from russia
ranging from diversifying supply sources
speeding up the development of
renewables becoming more energy
efficient and reducing natural gas
demand this winter
the eu and canada have been working
together to identify concrete and viable
areas for cooperation on the key energy
related commodities for which the eu has
a particular need liquefied natural gas
and hydrogen but also uranium critical
raw materials potash and biomass
we are grateful to canada for its
support and commitment to helping with
european energy security while deepening
cooperation on our mutual net zero
energy transition mr chair thank you
i thank you uh
ambassador um
next we have the ambassador of germany
to canada
um miss barwasser uh you of the floor
for your opening statement please
proceed
thank you mr chair
thank you very much for this opportunity
to appear at this hearing
the decision of the canadian government
to grant an exemption for the export of
the siemens gas turbine on request
of my country has given rise too much
controversy and criticism and i want to
give you the german perspective here
before i go into the arguments
allow me to place this question in a
larger context
this what we're leading today is a very
important debate but it is a debate
amongst very close partners and friends
we are all united and allied in our
strategic goal
russia must not win this war of
aggression against ukraine it must not
succeed in its attempt to reach or draw
the map by force
and it must not be allowed to destroy
the post-war security
order of europe
all governments called upon to witness
today here in this room
canadian european
german
we are all actively and unambiguously
supporting ukraine against the russian
aggression
we do it politically financially and
militarily including with heavier
weapons together with our partners in
the g7 we have decided on unprecedented
packages of far-reaching sanctions
and i want to stress it we are in this
for the long haul as chancellor schultz
just said we will support ukraine for as
long as it takes we want ukraine to be
free and sovereign and able to become
part of the european union
so our message today should be clear to
anybody and it certainly should be clear
to russia
we are ukraine's friends and firm allies
we will stay the course
so when we debate now the export of this
turbine or these turbines we depose
debate about a very important issue but
it's not a strategic one it's a tactical
one
both sides in this debate have valid and
weighty arguments
no decision is perfect none was easy
it was only after a lot of
soul-searching that germany asked canada
to allow a waiver of its national
sanctions regime and the canadian
government did grant it after difficult
deliberations we're very grateful for
the decision the reasoning behind our
request is simple our sanctions should
impose economic costs on russia but they
must not harm us more than that they
harm russian interest
as you well know many countries in the
eu including germany are still
decreasingly but still dependent on
russian gas for their energy supply and
that's just the reason why
europe and by the way the u.s sanctions
did not include sanctioning goods and
services related to the delivery of
russian gas
canada has been a leader within the g7
on sanctions against russia
canadian legislation has imposed
nationally a broader sanctions regime
it is geared to hurt russia it was
certainly not designed to make it harder
for the europeans to fill their gas
tanks while quickly replacing russian
gas
mr chair let me say sanctions are very
blunt instrument when states impose
economic cost on another country they
often inflict unintended consequences on
third parties
waivers allow flexibility and they allow
us to sharpen sanctions
all our countries use them
the u.s do it the eu just waived some
sanctions on russia to help open up for
ukrainian food exports and to take away
russia's pretext that the western
sanctions are to blame for the global
food food crisis
and for very similar reason germany
asked canada in june july to allow the
delivery of the turbines we did not want
to fall into putin's trap he pretended
that it was the lacking turbines that
was the reason why gasprom had to cast
delivery of gas to germany and to europe
we did not believe him then we do not
believe him now we have seen now how
russia finds more and more pretexts not
to take the turbines back and that is
really a case in point we have called
his bluff
with the delivery of turbine the pretext
was gone now it's clear for all to see
russia is using energy
to exert pressure on europe it's trying
to pit one ally against the other it
wants to divide us
we need to resist this
we also need
to get out of our dependency on russian
fossil fuels very fast germany has
already taken a lot of bold steps and
the eu has done it too as melitta
explained
we have achieved good progress on coal
we're getting we're out of it oil we're
going to be out of it very soon
and on gas well on february 24th
our dependency in germany from russian
gas imports stood at 55 percent
in the last few weeks it was down to 30.
i checked today we're down to 26 percent
that's huge progress
our goal is to fade our phase out
completely
out of russian energy as fast as we can
today germany as well as a considerable
number of other european countries we
will still need it in order to fill up
for the coming winter though we're
trying to fill up our gas storage as
fast as we can to 80 90 percent as the
backbone for the winter it's very
important for heating in europe
we're also preparing for the possibility
that russia will decide to cut off
europe completely or nearly completely
so nationally and on the eu level we're
con coordinating a whole measure a whole
bundle
of emergency measures and i will very
quickly name just four
we will bring back what we wanted to
phase out namely coal and that is very
painful
in phase of our climate targets
we're in the process also reassessing
our nuclear phase out we may prolong the
life cycle of our remaining nuclear
reactors
second point we share and we save the eu
has just relieved this gas saving plan
milita referred to it
and
hopefully
we
we will
save energy at a rate of 15 percent all
of the european countries and germany
even more third point
we diversify our partners in norway and
netherlands and the us have increased
their production in order to make up for
at least some of the shortfalls in
russian gas to receive liquefied gas
germany is installing now two lng ports
by the end of this year and probably two
to four more by the end of next year and
investor i'm uh sorry to uh am i doing
it
uh perhaps um
we could get you to wrap up uh what yeah
it's just that there's so many entities
that have questions no no no need to
apologize it's my job to be the heavy
please
i just want to say we're speeding up our
energy transition and we've changed our
legislation for that so just to say
we're preparing for very tough times and
we're trying to do it in a way that
keeps germany and keeps europe strong
economically and keeps our sort of the
consensus in our societies together we
need to do everything
in order to keep
us from being weakened if the economy in
europe and in germany stutters that
would entail also very heavy
repercussions for our joint ability to
continue our support of ukraine and my
last sentence is where i started we're
in this for the long haul we need to be
united we need to be strong we need to
be there for the support of ukraine and
the rebuilding of ukraine as a free and
sovereign nation in europe
thank you very much ambassador and uh
next we have uh ambassador kovalev uh
ukrainian ambassador to canada
uh you have the floor for your opening
remarks
dear mr chair dear members of the
committee thank you for this opportunity
to address
since february 21st as russia started
its unjustified war against ukraine it
uses wide range of weapons missiles
tanks sexual violence food and energy
we value canada's leadership and swift
parliamentary reactions to be the one of
the first countries to recognize russian
aggression and war crimes as a genocide
of ukrainian people
you stated the obvious and helped us
build alliances around the whole world
to recognize that russia goal is to
destroy ukraine as a sovereign country
and ukrainians as a nation we're also
grateful for
to canada for the steadfast support by
providing unprecedented financial
support military and humanitarian aid
hosting ukrainians who are fleeing the
war imposing sanctions being the first
to introduce tool to sasha russian
assets and ukraine is grateful for this
important actions of the direct support
but russia's ability to fuel the war is
built mainly on its oil and gas revenues
that have already exceeded 100 billion
dollars for the period of war the reason
why canada and other allies have imposed
sanctions is to deprive russia of the
revenues which is funds the war
we are united with eu partners on the
importance to reduce the dependency from
russian energy this dependency have been
built for decades and unfortunately
with ignorance of its true danger and
people who stood at the origin of this
irresponsible policy now visit moscow
for vocations
the urgent steps to decrease consumption
have been taken by eu and we as a
country had to make the serious steps in
2014 when ukraine totally cut off
russian gas supply to ukraine
and today i am addressing you not only
from the position of the country there
is over five months fighting for our
sovereignty but also from the country
that for the decade has been resisting
russia's energy pressure
our position from the very beginning
was that the decision to provide the
permit to siemens turbines was a
dangerous precedent that violates
international solidarity and goes
against the principle of rule of law and
in fact the waiver has already
strengthened moscow's sense of impunity
we repeat that we stated before it's
clear that russia's demand to turbines
has no technical basis and was aimed
only at putting even more pressure the
more you concede the more embodial
kremlin feels in pushing for further
exemptions simply put it's a slippery
slope
i would like to remind you the key fact
first
russia is able to continue full gas
supply to germany without the turbine
that was shipped to canada this turbine
is still in germany and gasprom
announced just yesterday that
it will not accept it
secondly
that's not true that ukraine cannot
deliver and substitute gas delivery to
germany
ukrainian against gas transition system
is 40 percent larger in terms of
capacity than nordstrom one and even
today the volume of gas that ukraine
delivers to europe is bigger
than nordstrom 1 delivers this
particular day ukraine route has
traditionally was delivering gas to
germany italy austria and other regions
and other countries of the region and
this is the only pipeline by russian
monopoly gastro has no stake
and it delivers gas to europe even
during the war
delivery through ukraine route would
also provide additional security for 11
million ukrainian households who are
getting the gas from the same pipeline
dear members of the committee this
waiver is not a one-time decision
the maintenance of all six turbines in
canada will cement russia's ability for
years ahead to weaponize energy and to
derail the efforts to address climate
change
and it will be done with canada's
blessing
the waiver
was issued in the claims for better
energy security but the latest weeks
have evidence that it only gave russia
grounds for further black mailing
russia hostile moves followed further
gas cut flow
announced another turbine to be out of
order and fully stopped gas supply to
latvia where canadian forces are
deployed
today 12 european countries have been
cut from russian gas supply on political
grounds
and russia is responsible of
orchestrating gas crisis in europe it's
now obvious
and the reason for the waiver was not to
allow russia to blame sanctions for the
disruption of gas supply and now it's
more than clear that additional five
turbines that were allowed to be further
maintained in canada will be turned by
russia into tools of humiliation
and we urge you do not take the bait
there was no need to waive the sanctions
to call putin's regime bluff and simply
liar
you just can google the history
and this logic of appeasement already
failed to prevent the war in ukraine
ukraine is eager to work with eu
countries on the measures to decrease
gas dependency we are committed to help
both by providing ukrainian gas route
offering ukrainian gas storages and by
supplying eu with additional electricity
that can substitute up to 5 billion
cubic meters of gas and we already are
on that way with eu we are looking
forward also to cooperate with canada on
energy security both for the renewables
hydrogen and supply of lng
let's not forget
that since the permit was issued russia
committed a series of war crimes
shopping mall in kremenchuk odessa
seaport killed over 50 prisoners of war
of assault star over 160 civilians have
been killed only in three weeks
ukraine needs further military support
to resist aggression on the battlefield
and we need sanctions to deprive russia
from economic ability to continue the
war
as stated
permit was issued with high hopes of the
government of canada to help strategic
partners in europe
since this step has obviously failed to
bring expected results we ask you to
revise this decision
the permit was stated to be revocable
and nobody wants other five turbines to
repeat the sad story of the current one
dear mr chair dear members of committee
the west has demonstrated unity and
commitment to stand with ukraine until
ukraine will wins the war
let's be tough let's be brave it's
ukrainians who are protecting the rest
of europe from russian barbarism
i have no doubt in your support for
ukraine and that your support to ukraine
will continue
and on behalf of all ukrainians for that
i want to thank you
thank you very much ambassador
we're going to go into our
first round of questions
first up is mr janice
for six minutes mr jennis you have the
floor
thank you chair my initial comments will
be to the german ambassador
your excellency as bit of a personal
introduction i'm i'm very proud of my
own german heritage my grandmother's
family were german jews and although
they lived through very dark times my
grandmother survived the war because of
the courage of many ordinary germans who
were willing to shelter her at great
risk to themselves she lived in the
munster area of germany where clemens
von galen spoke out boldly against
injustice and inspired everyday german
farmers to shelter my grandmother and to
sacrifice in the pursuit of justice
now i have been carefully reviewing the
arguments of your government on this
issue of the turbines
and there seems to be a lot of
commonalities and talking points with
the canadian government the same words
the same turns of phrase etc i note that
while you continually profess friendship
with ukraine and talk about unity you
seem to presume to know better than the
ukrainians do what is in their interest
it seems to me that saying you care but
failing to listen is not how true
friendship works now as it pertains to
the issue of energy your government is
first of all
acknowledging the reality that the
turbines are not needed and that as far
as the summer goes the maintenance is
routine your chancellor said explicitly
of the turbines that quote it would be
good if they would be there even though
they are not necessary end quote
the russians did not need to cut
production as a result of the absence of
a turbine the facts make this plane and
you have now acknowledged as much
instead as the ukrainian canadian
congress identified the russians were
running a test they were testing our
resolve and in particular your
government's resolve to see whether we
and you were ready to sustain support
for ukraine through arbitrary production
cuts
according to
multiple media reports your foreign
minister without claiming the turbines
were in any way necessary
told canada that if the missing turbine
led to a stoppage of natural gas from
russia it would spark popular uprisings
and force berlin to halt support for
ukraine in other words your government's
argument is not the turbines are needed
but rather that you do not believe that
the german people can stomach the
sacrifice that would be required if
russia continues to arbitrarily draw
down its gas supplies
sadly the implication of that argument
is that you would do almost anything to
get them to increase that supply of
course now that russia has seen your
response and has heard your government
say these things they will push further
and continue to use the threat of
arbitrary energy withdrawal to get
additional exemptions to sanctions and
other concessions now that russia has
seen and been told that you do not
believe the german people can sustain
serious sanctions and that the
withdrawal of energy will lead to
popular uprisings they will continue to
exert further pressure of course
and what what really strikes me and
bothers me about your government's
argument isn't just that it regurgitates
the failed talking points of appeasement
but that it seems to demonstrate a low
opinion of the courage and propensity
for sacrifice of your own people we all
know that sanctions involve sacrifice
stopping mutually beneficial exchanges
between people in different countries is
going to have negative consequences for
people on both sides that is inevitable
but while ukrainians are fighting and
dying not just for their freedom but for
ours as well i think the least that we
can all do is be prepared to bear the
sacrifice that sanctions require of us
we must be prepared to give until it
hurts if we want to prevail
um but your government seems to believe
that your own people uh would would give
in to the russian pressure and germans
would take to the streets if
if the turbines were not returned now
personally i have a much higher opinion
of the german people i believe that
germans have the potential for heroic
sacrifice and unlike these talking
points about popular uprisings i think
my view has public opinion data behind
it it was reported by the european
council on foreign relations that more
than half of germans already want to
maintain support to ukraine in spite of
high energy prices even absent any
leadership from the government on that
point when it comes to a willingness to
sustain the sacrifices that are required
to prevail against russia the problem is
not with the german people the problem
seems to be with the policy of the
german government and now the canadian
government now of course the challenges
german face germany faces are the result
of a situation uh they came about
because your country continued to take
russian gas between 2014 and 2021 even
though ukraine was already under russian
occupation
now your government uh i think should
acknowledge the reality that russia will
constrain or cut off supply in a time
and a way of their own choosing and the
only real alternative for germany is to
either completely acquiesce or to stand
firm and prepare for all possibilities
policies which become more and not less
likely with every concession
so ambassador those are my comments uh i
will say um i think you have maybe a
minute and a half left and i'll give you
the balance of my time to respond to
those comments as you wish
it's the chair am i am i allowed sorry
yes yes ambassador of the floor yes um
uh thank you mr genius um there were so
many points in there
my first point is
that i've made at the beginning of my
intervention is um
i can see both sides of the argument
these um
is it is a tactical decision it is a
tactical kind of
argument to be made what what is uh
the stronger measure we my government
and the canadian government has
also been convinced uh of that believe
that we have called putin's bluff by
actually honoring sort of the the part
of of the turbine delivery and we've
called the bluff because
it is now very clear to see that
russia is not has not been asking for
the turbines
in good faith and in order to
reset the
provision of gas it has done it
in order to blame us
with our own sanctions for the fact that
europe it will not perceive
receive any gas
second point like you i believe that the
german
population is very ready for sacrifice
and is very ready to stand behind
ukraine that's this is absolutely true
and if you've seen in berlin the welcome
that ukrainian families have received
when they came
we have about 900 000 ukrainian refugees
and people are very happy to welcome
more of them you have a very good point
when you say we made a huge strategic
mistake by creating such a dependency on
russia it is a grievous mistake it
happened over many many decades it was
also part of a policy of trying to tie
russia into a european security system
it followed the fall of the war where we
saw russia
a member of the european security system
i'm in the unenviable position of having
to cut off an ambassador i don't i don't
i don't cherish it but mr zuberry is up
next for six minutes and perhaps he'll
let you complete your thoughts i'll
leave that to him mr zabari you have the
floor
thank you mr morans um and i'd like to
thank all the ambassadors for being here
and um recognize that we are all
standing in solidarity with ukraine each
and every one of us um
from from canada uh to europe and um i'd
also like to thank the panel for
acknowledging that um that um canadian
sanctions um against russia
uh in their pursuit of this illegal war
are very robust um
i'd also like to thank um the the
our german allies and all european
allies and their steadfastness um in in
confronting russia and supporting the
ukrainian people
um this being said i'd like to start off
with um the ambassador uh our foreign
affairs minister earlier in the previous
panel um said that sanctions should aim
whenever possible to pressure russia
firmly clearly uh but also to avoid
unintended consequences
upon our allies um does the eu share
this view
you're on mute still
ambassador you you have the floor uh mr
chair if i may answer uh yes yes uh
thank you thank you for this question uh
honorable zabari mp
yeah the short
answer to your question is the european
union is determined to minimize uh
unintended consequences of our very
serious sanctions for third countries as
well as for european
economy thank you for that um and and i
know that we all say this together while
being very steadfast against what russia
is doing uh
and supporting ukrainian people
um
now to both um the eu ambassador and the
german ambassador um our minister uh mr
wilkinson said that um they there were
no other alternatives to this decision
when it came to providing the turbine
uh can you speak about the importance of
this decision to germany
and um do in your view were there
alternative decisions that could have
been made by canada
to both ambassadors garbick and
sparrowser
during the question period you can just
assume you have the floor in response to
a question ambassadors
melita
yes uh thank you thank you sabine so um
i i want to
reiterate uh what i already said in my
opening statement which is that we do uh
welcome
canada's decision uh to repatriate this
turbine uh both because uh it
uh it took away the pretext that
that russia has been using for reducing
the flow of gas
but also but also because
as you are all aware
europe has found itself in this
situation with energy security uh
because of russia's
aggression against ukraine and because
europe the european union and its member
states decided to support ukraine very
very firmly uh with uh you know
different means as i already explained
ranging from financial military uh
political
uh the um also um also uh support for
refugees and so forth uh and uh we are
determined to wean ourselves off russian
energy in order to do so we
need to uh we need to uh do that
gradually we already decided to uh to
ban 90 of imports of fresh and crude oil
we already uh banned
import of russian coal and we are
determined to uh uh phase out our
dependency on russian gas
now in the meantime in the short term we
need to prepare for the winter
and whatever flow of gas
can come to europe
is of course helping with
filling up our storages and as uh
sabine already referred to we've decided
uh to fill our storages uh up to 80 to
90 percent by the end of the year or by
the beginning of
november and here i also want to
emphasize that we already
increased
imports of
gas natural gas from other than
than
russian sources by 75 percent uh
compared to last year
thank you for that um
and uh ambassador spywasser do you have
anything to add to that
it just want melita said we're very
grateful that canada sort of changed um
or took the waiver in order to avoid
unintended consequences of its uh
sanctions it was something that has been
discussed amongst the g7 as well and
our u.s partners also welcomed that
decision in the meantime with
other sanctions we have been going ahead
and we have been trying to find
sanctions that really hurt
russian interests
very effectively so
it is sort of a process that we do
together
thank you um
with with respect to
i i know hypotheticals are are things
that we don't want to generally engage
in but when it comes to um german's
concern germany's concerns around if the
government of canada did not grant this
permit what would have transpired can
you please elaborate upon that
ambassador sparrowser
well it's a fifth dimension it's
speculation but i do believe that um the
reduction of the use of of the flow of
gas in north stream one would have been
entirely blamed on the sanctions of
the g7 and the eu against russia so it
would have been we're fighting a hybrid
war it's a war on a conventional war
that um ukraine uh suffers and fights
very very bravely but we're also in a
war on energy we're in a war on food
supplies and we're in a disinformation
war and
i think our
point of view was that we would have
lost significantly in the disinformation
war if that turbine had not been able to
be delivered right now this turbine sits
in germany it is very clear that it was
an excuse it was a pretext because
gaspam is not picking it up and they're
inventing very strange
excuses for not doing i
have to move on now to mr bergeron who
has the floor for six minutes
merci merci
thank you thank you mr chair i would
like to thank the three ambassadors for
being with us today
it is indeed very much appreciated
my first question
will be to her excellency
ukraine's ambassador madame kovalev
we've been hearing since the beginning
of these meetings of these sessions an
argument which says that this
authorization
to allow this turbine to go back to
germany allowed
in fact uh gave us the opportunity of
calling putin's bluff everyone seems to
agree on the fact that vladimir putin
set out a trap for us but are you not
under the impression that we fell into
that trap
thank you
i think uh
there is no need as i've said to waive
the sanctions to call putin's bluff and
if we call back to january this year
i will quote we will not attack raid or
invade ukraine that was russian deputy
foreign minister saying in january this
year and this and many other examples
including for example 24 hours after
istanbul initiative was signed putin was
with the missiles attacking odessa port
where the first vessel was
preparing to follow to istanbul and then
to lebanon
and i think this is
what we already understand and it's good
to hear that both
german government canadian government eu
one more time understood and evidenced
that putin bluffs and with this turbine
which almost three weeks already in
germany
and yesterday very clearly gaspron said
that it will not accept it
so the thing is that
why should the other five turbines
need to be sent
to germany and then to russia and we
need to all to understand that this
waiver is not a waiver to send the
turbulence in germany in precise and
everybody knows this the waiver directly
to russian war machine guest prom
and that is the evidence what we all
understand now so i think this debate
today need to be focused on stopping
and not allowing putin for the blackmail
our eu partners
and fueling the energy war
so and this is the only way to do it
it's to revoke and it was as it was
stated that the permit is revocable is
to revoke this permit
thank you
eric sanchez
as the black quebecois we've clearly
established that the
the uh
the following that germany and canada in
fact would
would heighten the level of sanctions to
compensate for this transfer uh be it in
terms of military aid given to ukraine
or elsewhere
canada has made many announcements when
it comes to sanctions and military
assistance
when it comes to sanctions we've said
this many times before we are not fully
sure that the government of canada
exactly knows the impact of these
sanctions what these impacts are when it
comes to military assistance i think you
would be in a position to be able to to
tell us what the real impact of these
promises of military assistance is
are you able to receive military
assistance within the
timelines
thank you
first of all
let me thank you for
unprecedent financial support that
canadian government has already provided
to ukraine that helps a lot to many of
the ukrainians to to
have the access to
the social support
in the country in the world
and
since we are fighting
uh for our sovereignty on the
battlefield every day
the
so much needed military support in
ukraine is the urgent issue this was as
we discussed with you when you invited
me the first time and many other
meetings that we discussed with you it's
it's really crucially important to
to not only the uh
announce this
the military support but we need it on
the battlefield because each day we are
losing the best ukrainians to protect
our country and we would much welcome
that we will have in three weeks the
independence day of ukraine the
disannounced military support will be
a great present to ukrainian soldiers on
our independence day
thank you your excellency i would like
to now ask a question to the ambassador
of the federal republic of germany
excellency i'm adam shkarwasser
your excellence i was a bit surprised in
your opening remarks not to have heard a
couple words from
in french
because you have beautiful french skills
but you were on power on politics nbc's
program on the 12th of july you said
that
the transfer of the turbine helped
germany
save itself from dependency on russian
energy how did the turbine exactly do
that when it comes to procuring energy
produced by russia
thank you mr bergeron i will try to
respond a bit in french but it's going
to be a bit more difficult for me
of the turbine
was
supposed to be
a measure that would allow more gas to
flow initially we were not sure this
would happen we were testing um
what would happen um
but we
had our doubts from the beginning that
the russians would increase the flow of
gas it would be for the european sake
for many states in the european union
and for us it would be very would have
been very beneficial if that had
happened in order to to fill our
reservoirs
right now we're at a 20
sort of flow and um i don't think we're
having very high expectations that this
is going to increase
what it has done now is to make it very
very clear that the turbine was not the
issue it's the willingness of russia
to try and divide europe to sort of cut
europe off and we are now preparing very
actively for the emergency that may be
coming this winter
milita has named the emergency plans
that the eu is preparing
i have started to
tell a little bit about all the measures
germany is taking very drastic measures
in order to get out of the dependency
thank you
ambassador ms mcpherson youth floor for
six minutes
thank you mr chair and and i do want to
thank all of the ambassadors for being
with us here today i know this is this
is very challenging and i i want to say
that that i think the one thing that we
all agree on is the importance of
supporting ukraine i know that that that
we all want to see this horrific um
invasion this horrific war
uh end we all want to see a strong
sovereign ukraine um and so you know
forgive me for if i if my questions come
across as as harsh but of course as as a
member of the opposition my role is to
is to question some of the decisions
that the government has made and make
sure that they are the right decisions
so
um
you know with that in mind i think i
think we all can can celebrate the fact
that there is such um a desire for
ukraine to to triumph in this in this
war uh well there are discrepancies on
what we do what we think should happen
next this this desire for for ukraine to
triumph i think is very strong and i
think it's important uh that the russian
federation knows that and knows how how
um
how together we are on that goal um
but i am going to start with a few a few
questions if i could to to our german
ambassador to um to ambassador of ussr
um
you know
obviously when the when the turbine was
returned um you know right now we have
we have hindsight and and of course
hindsight is 2020. but now we know that
the the russian federation that putin
has no intention of fulfilling its
promises
so in fact
how has the decision to send the turbine
back how has that actually helped the
german people how how is that not just
you know
undermined
canada's sanctioned regime and our and
our collective sanction regime
and not helped germany in any way
thank you for that question i mentioned
the disinformation war
we are all in our society subject to
russian disinformation
in canada as much as in germany
to have
the pretext to have russia be able to
say
that
the fact that we didn't return the
turbine is the reason why no more gas is
not flowing would have been
a
a pretty difficult argument in the indie
disinformation war the way we have it
now the turbine is there they can have
it it's not the turbine that's the issue
on the energy supply makes it absolutely
crystal clear to anybody that russia has
been
has been lying about it and this is not
a necessary thing so in that sense we
caught that bluff i think that is
actually
a good thing and a good outcome of the
um uh this very very difficult uh um a
very difficult procedure and i do want
to i just yeah just if i could interrupt
sorry but
knowing then that this is the reality
that we're in that we've now as in your
words called called putin's bluff and
that we are in a situation where we know
that this was never his intention to to
provide the the natural gas that or the
gas that germany requires um do you
think that we should be revoking this
waiver do you think that because clearly
sending another five is is just you know
bad pennies after after good like why
would we do this now why would we not
revoke the waiver as ukraine is asking
us to do
what is the value of that now we've
proven
that putin has no intention to live up
to his obligations there is no benefit
to the german people so i don't
understand why we wouldn't revoke that
waiver at this point
well i think that's something to decide
and obviously with the turbine not being
picked up that question absolutely
arises and
i think we will discuss that in the near
future right now i can't give an answer
to that but right um now there is one
turbine russia doesn't seem to want to
pick it up has declared it won't pick it
up and this is sort of um the next steps
to consider
okay thank you um and then i actually
have a question if i could for for
ambassador gabriel uh could you tell me
you know you you speak of the support of
the european union in this in this
situation does that include all members
of the european union can you clarify
whether there was support for this
decision from from countries like poland
latvia lithuania estonia
thank you thank you for this question i
would like to clarify
that uh the european union uh passed
seven packages of sanctions against
russia
and that all sanctions are uh actually
accepted in unity
meaning that all 27 member states have
to agree and all 27 member states agreed
to all seven packages of sanctions
but did they did they was there
unanimous support to
for canada to waive
this particular sanction was there
support from other countries to waive
to to support canada's decision to waive
the sanction on the gas turbines
the executive uh branch of the european
union the european commission
welcomed the decision by canada to
repatriate the turbines as i explained
earlier both in terms of
taking away the pretext as well as
for potentially helping with uh filling
up the storage gas storages uh for the
winter so the executive branch but
perhaps not the not all of the members
of the european union is that accurate
this welcome uh was uh actually uh
issued by the executive branch the
european commission okay thank you
um and i have you know i'm gonna go back
and ask one more question if i could um
of ambassador
um ambassador sparvasser
so so
in july deputy prime minister free
christian freeland um said that she
understood ukraine's response but that
she defended the government's move she
said and i quote that canada heard very
clearly from our german allies that
germany's ability to sustain its support
for ukraine could be at risk
um you know she mentioned that the
united states backed this that it was a
position that freeland described as very
significant i'm just wondering if you
could share with us what was the support
that the german government
was worried that they would have to
withhold if canada did not return those
turbines to germany
there was
not
a sort of a discussion of withholding
any kind of support to ukraine we stand
solidly behind ukraine and we have been
amongst the strongest donors on every
type of aid on ukraine
what um the remark is referring to is
indeed what i've been saying earlier
we're in it for the long haul we need to
be able to sustain it as an economy as
an economy that's a very important part
of the european union and the motor in
it we need to sustain it also
in also in face of a lot of
disinformation
we need to have the full support of our
population which we have now but we need
to also keep it up because we need to
keep up that support for the long haul
and we need um to help support ukraine
looking towards reconstruction as well
and again we need a solid your german
european customer
thank you very much for that mr bazan
you of the floor for six minutes please
proceed
thank you mr chair and i want to thank
uh all three ambassadors for joining us
today it's uh good to see you all
um
would like to um
first of all i want to thank uh ukraine
and uh having uh ambassador kovalev here
and just say first of all all of ukraine
is in our thoughts and prayers we know
that you're on the front line standing
up for western democracy standing up for
human rights and fighting against
putin's war machine i'd also want to say
this that
as conservatives if we were government
we would never circumvent our own
sanctions regime we would not have
approved the export of the turbines to
germany in fact we would have dived in
and worked with germany to provide more
of our own natural gas we would have
been making sure that there was canadian
oil and other energy products available
and essentially we would want to work
with
our friends in germany on making sure
that they would keep open their
nuclear power plants to provide the
energy they need to power their homes
and and their industries especially
during this time of transition away from
uh the dependency on russian energy
products
um
ambassador uh kovalev you you you've
talked about you know that this is
appeasement uh often we uh talk about
important moments in time as a
chamberlain moment or a churchill moment
uh do you believe that uh canada uh and
our allies on this issue of the turbines
did a bit of peace as a chamberlain
moment rather than standing up lake
churchill
thank you and
one more time i would like to thank you
for for this committee and for the uh
parliament for the
uh united support for ukraine
with you've done a lot including the
motion on the genocide uh the support of
the legislation of scientific assets and
canada has been
leader and example for many sanctions
that canada was imposing the first
and it is when we do value it
and this is as president zelensky
mentioned it is a very dangerous
precedent and we don't want i think
nobody
of us want to be also the president
the others to follow by the negative one
um in terms of the uh decision we i
think um
and we heard today the arguments and we
heard these arguments while we were
discussing and ukrainian government
ukrainian ministers have some
discussions with uh
with
canadian ministers and with german
government on on these
and we were from the beginning
because we as ukraine have went through
this russian energy terrorism
i don't know whether
everybody knows but russia has already
switched gas to ukraine in during the
winter three times already 2006 2009 and
2014. so when we were saying from the
very first time that
they are bluffing and there will be no
renewal of gas supply
um
i don't want to to say it blunt but but
we said and it actually we are where we
are and even more
uh because when turbine arrived to
germany gaspron further decreased gas
flow and this is what we understand
uh from both of the history on dealing
with energy terrorism by russia but also
was dealing with a direct and very
barbaric war in ukraine putin
understands only power and pull putting
understanding strange and in this
particular situation what we see that
putin and his um gas monopoly gas
problem is using the power of supplier
and the europe and our old european
allies and together with ukraine we are
ready to support to use
a power of consumer and not undermine
this and that's why we proposed a very
pragmatic actions not to just uh cut the
the gas flow to ukraine but we proposed
alternatives that are on the table and
by the way they are today delivering
because too many european countries
i appreciate that ambassador excellency
i just know i got very limited time here
and i just want to ask two very
short yes and no uh questions one uh to
to our ambassador from ukraine uh do you
need does ukraine need more military
weapons uh like um sniper rifles like uh
armored ambulances and also if if
they're just hold on i got also a
question for uh our ambassador uh sparta
uh sparta wiser uh but uh you know more
military support especially in light of
of um the i guess the slighter hand of
moving these turbines and putting more
gas and putin's war machine and also uh
to to to to our german ambassador friend
uh is there a moral obligation here um
by
um germany and the eu for that matter uh
to to
to make those sacrifices you talked
about so that we can stop the genocide
and the war
crimes that are being committed against
ukraine
yes or no
i think we feel a strong moral
obligation to support ukraine in its um
battle against the russian aggression
and germany has changed its policy
180 degrees um two days after after the
attack germany has
by now delivered
a lot of weapons i can give you access
to the full list if you want but by um
is also in the process of delivering
some very heavy multiple launch rocket
systems whole bridges
i'm just checking gapa tanks which are
anti-aircraft tanks so we're sending
very serious
uh
heavy weapons to ukraine in order to
help it defend itself we're also
supporting ukraine as one of its biggest
donors financially and in every other
way we can
um mr prasad i have been uh fairly
lenient with time in this particular
meeting
but we are well over six minutes so i'm
going to uh move on to cervera who has
the floor for six
yeah
minutes
ambassador which one was
sorry can i can i ask you all can i
answer the question for me as well um
let me mr subbera how would you feel
about uh the ambassador answering this
question under your
your time and then you can
thank you chair i will definitely if the
the ambassador wishes to take up some of
my time uh provide her the time at this
moment to answer that question
absolutely please thank you very much
ambassador great to see you today great
to see thank you um my short answer will
be yes we do value the support of all
our allies germany canada the us all the
european union and other countries and
yes we do need more military support
chair i'll begin now
yes i i'm sorry clerk i just need to
clarify is mr bear is around five or six
minutes
sorry mister clerk mr five five okay my
apologies so mr ferry let's go five
minutes from now you go ahead uh
thank you uh thank you chair good
afternoon uh first thing i i i would i
have to say this because i would be
remiss if i didn't uh i have uh three
beautiful daughters at home and uh they
are growing and and uh blessed to have
them and i see three ambassadors who are
female today so are
so kudos to that and i do want to point
that out because
as much as we're talking about many
issues of the world uh the women's
rights and gender equality is something
that's very very important to our
government and important to myself as a
father of three girls uh and i do wish
to point i just want to say welcome to
ambassador
gabriel uh nice to see you again as the
chair of the canada your parliamentary
association we've had many great
conversations and the recent trip to the
council of europe was a very productive
one for myself and uh mp bergeron was on
the trip as well and i know we had a lot
of great discussions uh with actually
including the delegation from uh ukraine
uh we spent a lot of time uh with them
and uh and uh and uh it was very very
fruitful discussions uh on to uh the
matters at home because there are
matters at hand excuse me because they
are very serious and and one thing i've
learned in politics it's easy to get
into monday morning quarterbacking and
uh and looking back and and uh laying
blame or saying you made a mistake
because they're in the past and you can
only move forward to make decisions
going forward
in governing you have to make tough
decisions and you have to make tough
choices
obviously we made a decision in terms of
shipping back the turbines uh to to
germany or to mainland europe uh to be
used in the the the for the pipeline and
i think i
fundamentally believe it was the right
decision i had stated that to the
ministers in our government and it was
the right decision and i think our
allies have uh have backed that but
there is a there is a conversation going
on in terms of a strategic transition of
europe's energy flows and energy
security is so so important uh for
europe and yes there's a dependence this
dependence being is being reduced and
it's so important to keep the european
populace the european population of the
everyday european that is facing uh very
high inflation rates very very high
energy rates uh on side and to keep our
allies united and i believe
fundamentally uh putin uh in whatever
term you want to reference uh the the
person uh is only about dividing us and
whether it's free whether it's
disinformation whether it's using food
as a weapon or energy as a weapon so i i
do first want to turn to the the german
ambassador uh i read your comments um i
i do want you to if you could please
reiterate the transition plans uh in
terms of reducing uh germany's
dependence on russia as an energy source
please
thank you mr zabara for that question so
germany is trying to get out of russian
gas as fast as possible we have reduced
from 55 right now to 26 of dependents
we're doing um
enormous efforts to save energy we're
doing enormous efforts to diversify by
getting more energy supplies for many of
our partners and filling our reservoirs
in view of a potentially very difficult
winter
and we're speeding up
with
every
sort of drive we have we're speeding up
the energy transition germany has passed
a number of laws so that we can now
build renewable energy much much faster
it's being declared in the national
interest and security interest to build
up renewable energy fast and
we are building up in at very high speed
also lng capacity we are looking towards
trying to
find long-term partners we're also
looking towards canada
for lng as a transitional energy but
mostly also for green hydrogen as the
energy of the future and we're going to
invest a lot of
drive into that
mr barry you still there
apologies i was i guess i got rusty on
the on the turning off the uh unmuting
um just to clarify here uh 40 seconds
the ukrainian ambassador left the
meeting
i do not see her on screen
she's in the oh she's in the room thank
you yeah okay uh too quickly to to
ambassador gabriel and then to the
ukrainian ambassador ambassador gravik
gabrick you're here on the ground in
canada can you please uh tell us how the
relationship is between yourself the
european union and canada in relation to
working on the many issues facing
ukraine facing uh energy security for
europe uh and doing the right thing for
the longer term and then to the
ukrainian ambassador i'll turn over you
for the last 20 seconds if you have any
closing comments in terms of what i've
stated please ambassador gabric
thank you mp sir bara um very quickly so
uh we have
had an excellent cooperation with canada
we have been working together to support
ukraine uh to uh also to coordinate to
inform each other about the sanctions
against russia and we have been looking
just to uh and analyzing how canada can
help europe with the energy security uh
among other things we have now this
working group on energy security that
was established
in march
and that is actually looking at all
these potential sources of energy that
could be imported to europe from canada
including lng including hydrogen
but also
enhancing our cooperation on uh critical
raw materials
all of this in the context of our
our
commitments to a
green
transition and to zero a net zero
economy by 2050.
so as i said in my opening statement we
very much appreciate canada's uh
proactive uh investment in european
security and uh and in uh in supporting
uh in supporting uh ukraine uh but also
uh everything that canada is doing uh
all its efforts to find ways to help uh
europe also uh within all of you as we
are quite a bit over time on mr sobera's
round i'm gonna have to move on to uh
bergeron for two and a half minutes you
have the floor mr bergeron mercedes
thank you mr chair
my question will be to the ambassador of
ukraine
now
given the dead end that we're facing
right now
the alternative of the ukrainian
pipeline should it be considered once
again by europe
thank you
um i i think that uh
we we were much discussing today about
the decision was made but i think it is
also important now one more time to
realize where we are now was this
decision and we are now was this this
decision not only when the first turbine
stuck in germany but also with the
decisions that the other five
uh that will be uh waived to maintain in
canada will actually uh will allow for
another at least four or five years for
gas prom to manipulate and to terrorize
europe on the energy market and also we
need to be aware that they will
definitely use it
to tackle our climate change goals
because for them it also a huge
challenge
while they are the biggest energy
producer we know that we see it in
ukraine russian missiles already hit 90
percent of all of the wind farms they
have been stolen and destroyed solar
farms they are precisely attacking and
we see it in in our territory all of the
renewable energy because this is the
threat they also have been um
for the many decades supplying ukraine
with
cheap gas so that all of the ukrainian
production uh dropped down significantly
and only since 2014 ukraine cut off the
gas supply from russia direct and
increased a lot in our own production so
it is a very dangerous move
to leave these other turbines because we
leave the door open for putting steel
for the blackmail europe and and i think
that is and i do agree with uh
ambassador uh
sparwasser that it's right now to sit
down all together and rethink because
the first attempt to plea putin
failed as it was obvious for us and now
it's the right time to
to revoke the sanctions
permit to revoke the pyramid
what do you think of the
ukrainian pipeline alternative
from the very first
day we
proposed to use ukrainian pipelines
today a ukrainian pipeline is already
supplying physically more gas to europe
than
north stream one
and
ukraine uh trans transmission system is
the biggest in europe ukraine has the
biggest gas storages and historically
this pipeline and the flow of gas from
europe uh from russia to europe was done
through ukrainian route and it's also
worse to know that casprom booked the
capacity
paid for it but using even now 40
percent for what was booked so if today
guest prom wants to help germany uh with
the gas supply gasprom can do it but we
all realize with all of the uh with all
of the waivers that guest prom does not
want it but still we are ready to do it
we are also working with other other
partners including moldova
including
our regional partners like czech
republic poland hungary to find the new
instrument of the infrastructure new
corridors so that the lng flow that is
coming to the countries who now
physically have the lng terminals in
europe so that these gas can move also
to to the other countries of the region
so we were quite open with this and
initially ambassador all right thank you
i have to move on unfortunately these
rounds are very tight and we've been
going on a bit but uh miss first send
you the floor for two and a half minutes
thank you very much mr chair and i and i
do want to again thank the ambassadors
for all being here i know this is a very
difficult conversation i mean i i
appreciate your honesty and your um your
candor and sharing with us uh i didn't
get an opportunity to say this to the to
ambassador
and i wanted to just make sure i got
that on the record that that i i want to
congratulate you and the german
government for your reduction in
reliance on russian gas i think it's
very very important that we note that um
you know to be at 26
in such a short period of time is really
really remarkable and so thank you for
the efforts that have been done by the
government by yourselves and by by the
german people uh the questions that i
have today
um now are for ambassador kovalev
ambassador it's lovely to see you i wish
i could see you in person that that pin
on your breast looks beautiful on your
on your jacket um what i'm worried about
here is is what it means with this this
when we have when we have um allowed
putin to blackmail us when we have
allowed him to act with impunity with
regards to this to this um
to this turbine and i wonder if you
could comment on whether or not you are
worried whether or not you think that it
is possible that other countries will
take this waiver as an excuse for them
to not live up to the sanctions that
they have put in place if that is a if
that is a risk that you have and and
particularly around energy but also
around food because we do know that as
well russia is using food as a weapon of
war
thank you uh for that question and
yes this was the very first argument
that russia is testing
our unity and is testing and pushing to
pushing
to concessions
and every every in each concession is
actually allows russia to move further
and even with this particular case
there are the other black male language
coming from russia if we look on their
statements one of that was issued
yesterday now they blaming not only
canada sanctions but also eu and uk
sanctions
does it mean that everybody will also
follow the uh example of canada and make
their own waivers
that was a very
dangerous precedent and i think it's
important now to realize that these
concessions
does not have any real impact as we see
us with with this turbine and that is
important and that is important to
actually to fix the situation to revoke
this pyramid and to show putin that
um actually
we are all united and strong
showing him that we will not do further
such mistakes
thank you ambassador um now
i'm the next round so um i'm going to
pass the chair to mr bergeron do you
accept the chair mr bergeron
will be sure
yes of course mr chair
mr morantz you have the floor
thank you very much um ambassador
sparkwasser i i just want to seek some
clarity
on um how this came about so when you
when you decided you wanted the return
of the um
of the of turbine you came to the
canadian government
and as as concisely as you can what were
the specific reasons
uh you made uh to minister jolie and
minister wilkinson and others in the
liberal government
for the return of the turbines
excellence
merci
the um
the
government
and that means in this case
it was mainly minister habek wrote a
letter to minister wilkinson in which he
explained that the turbine was
a contractual obligation of siemens to
uh provide service and maintenance uh to
north stream one and this was a crucial
part
of maintaining north stream one from
from
functioning
and
or at least that the russian government
was saying this was a crucial part and
that the turbine
was very important
to
continue to provide
the
the functioning of north stream one for
european
countries that wanted to fill
their
gas reservoirs um he didn't or we didn't
say that we totally believed this to be
the reason we always were quite aware
that this might be a pretext but it was
the reason given
uh thank you so
so you never made the argument then that
um canada should return the turbine
to call mr putin's bluff
during those discussions is that correct
no that's not true that was that was uh
that argument was made
and uh um so i i guess what i'm
struggling with is uh when the
news first broke that the canada was
going to break sanctions and return the
turbine that wasn't uh the explanation
that was given
that mr putin's bluff needed to be
called the explanation that was given by
your government and
and our government was that natural gas
supplies needed to be restored to
germany so i'm wondering if that's the
case if that argument was made why
wasn't uh why wasn't your government and
our government transparent
about the
actual reasons
not just the flow of natural gas
and you made it clear in your statement
you didn't believe mr putin then and you
don't believe him now so you never
believed
that the
mr putin would increase the flow of
natural gas
so that leaves me to believe that the
real reason was that you wanted to call
mr putin's bluff so why not in early
july
publicly say that why wait until
gasprom has refused to accept delivery
of the turbine to say it
seems very odd to me yeah um mr morris
um the
um what we didn't believe was that the
delivery of the turbine was absolutely
crucial to the technical ability of
north stream one to continue to function
that was what we doubted from the very
beginning that this was
the case
but
we thought or we
argued that it was important to fulfill
that obligation in order to make it
quite clear that there is a political
will to deliver the gas or not to
deliver gas
very quick very quickly really it's a
yes sir
it really it's a very simple answer why
didn't you advise the public when the
announcement was made that it was to
call putin's bluff
because that's what you're saying now
why not a month ago when the canadian
government did why don't you say that to
the why didn't you give that information
to your your uh
your public and
yeah why
we um
we thought that the turbine was
potentially
a
a way of continuing more gas supplies
and we wanted to test it um it doesn't
but you said in your opening statement
we did not believe him then and we do
not believe him now so you never
believed that the gas would a flow would
improve it was always about the bluff
according to you today it was always
about about uh thinking that um
insisting on the turbine was uh
insisting that the turbine was
absolutely technically um
necessary that was always the question
that we had and we had it from the very
beginning we were very transparent about
it um i could
i can't find it to you in a hurry right
now i could read you the interviews
that minister habek gave and it is very
clear that this was the case
mr moranza i would need to
cut your time and give the share back to
you
thank you very much i accept the chair
mr bergeron
and
i believe i'm the next liberal speaker
mr chair
we're not hearing you mr chair
um uh the clerk has texted me that it's
mr sarai but uh it's okay with him um
ms ben diane you have the floor
thank you mr chair um
uh
thank you to
our three ambassadors appearing before
the committee today
um uh your excellency ambassador
sparwatzer i think i'll begin um
by
by asking you in in light of comments
that i referenced earlier in a in a
previous meeting today of your foreign
minister but also of several comments
that you made in in your introduction a
few moments ago
you mentioned that the reduction of the
flow of
gas through north nordstrom one would
have been entirely blamed on the
sanctions
and you also
stated later in your introduction um
that there would be heavy repercussions
for your ability to continue your
support of ukraine and so i i would like
to hear you um on
the consequences of canada
um having
refused to grant um the request of
germany how do you feel
that would have affected
the support of the alliance the support
of germany but also of other european
partners
for these sanctions
given the impact on on your population
thank you
i believe uh i've mentioned that
beforehand that this is a hybrid uh kind
of war and it's a disinformation war and
to have given the argument to the
russians that we brought the same the
the the lack of gas upon ourselves uh
would have been a strong argument in the
death information war that um and the
consequence of that disinformation to
your people
well it it could erode our our support
in the long term but
as i say right now support is strong but
we want to keep it that way
um
the
the previous conservative member
asked
quite a few questions about the
importance of
or not of calling mr putin's bluff and
and
and and questioned um
you know the the public communication
around uh calling
um president putin's bluff um
obviously uh as a poker player i feel
quite strongly that you don't announce
um that you're calling somebody's bluff
when you do it but um i do have a
follow-up question to that line uh of
thought and that is um
now that we have called
russia's bluff is it germany's view
that
canada could revoke the permit um and uh
you know
following the the request of course by
the the ukrainian
ambassador today
well i think we have to see what happens
now with the turbine nuts there i would
hesitate
any kind of guesses on what's going to
follow but obviously if russia doesn't
pick up the turbine that's sitting there
ready and in perfect condition it
creates a different kind of situation
and and so if the turbine never does
make it to russia and continues uh to
stay in germany would it would it be
germany's position and that we could
revoke the permit
uh i don't think we have a position i
think we now have a decision by the
canadian government to support us in
this and
we will see what happens we have to see
what happens
thank you ambassador and um ambassador
kovalev i i also wanted to uh of course
thank you for your testimony today and
um for reiterating um your uh gratitude
for canada's support at our last meeting
you um you insisted uh you know on the
importance of canada's unprecedented
financial and military support and and
of course indicated that the history
books would would remember um that
canada stood shoulder to shoulder with
ukraine um that continues uh obviously
to be a a priority for our government
and i hope that that continues to be the
way that your government and that
ukraine views are our steadfast support
for ukraine and that this decision was
taken in in the context which i just
mentioned of the importance of ensuring
that these sanctions remain in place in
the continued unity of the alliance
so first of all i would like also to
thank you for as i've already mentioned
for the steadfast support
of canadian government
german government eu government and many
allies
we see on the ramstein format which
was already several times the number of
countries who are sitting in the table
and coordinating the support of ukraine
first of all the military support of
ukraine is increasing each day because
each day the world understands
uh that the war in ukraine it's not only
the
russian barbarism
on one country
the consequences of this war is far
below ukraine and even
eu borders these dimensions of this
russian aggression as we are today
discussing the energy security uh the
food security the nuclear security on
the european continent there are many
things that this war
brought to the global peace and global
order the challenges
and
and there is a
very clear
thing that
where we are on the opposite side if we
look what russia is doing on energy
um and terrorizing europe
we on the contrary are trying our best
to as much as possible deliver food and
ukrainian grain to the global markets
under the threats unfortunately many
ukrainian farmers are dying on the
fields because of the mines because of
these shellings but despite that we are
planting we are collecting harvest with
a great support of canadian government
for helping ukraine to buy so needed
grain storages to allow
the world to get the ukrainian grains
the first ship already went through even
after russian missiles attack hit the
port the sec next 16s are already coming
waiting to come for that
and
while russia is doing the opposite and
turbine is an exact
very blunt
showcase of how they are threatening the
the continent i think we need to be
clear on
punishing russia for that
and as we are talking that the
consequences of
sanctions need
don't need to hurt
everybody
yes in the short period of time but we
need to consider what will happen if our
policy of appeasing putin
will
enforce him to move further
and we need to understand what
consequences will be on that thank you
uh thank you ambassador sergeant uh mr
clerk i realize we're at the hour i was
wondering if um
there's a committee
support for another
round of 15 minutes
sure
as everyone agreeable to that
ambassadors uh and members of parliament
if that's the case um there's four
there's four there's four uh rounds
correct
um
so maybe we'll do um
five
five two and a half two and a half
mr uh genus is up next uh you have the
floor for five minutes please proceed
well thank you uh mr chair um
it's clear to me as we get to the end of
of the day of hearings um
there's a consensus that the delivery
of the turbine has and will
not achieve anything practically in
terms of access to gas
this was supposed to be rather about
exposing the russians and removing an
excuse um
one turbine has now been said the
russians have not restored the flow
um i i do not believe setting that
turbine was the right decision but if it
had any purpose at all the turbine has
sent been said that is it has it has
exposed the point at the very least i
think we should be able to agree that no
more turbines should be said uh and we
on this side are strongly in support of
the call from the ukrainian ambassador
to at this point revoke the permit
um it should be obvious that if if the
government's rationale holds uh that the
objective they said they were trying to
achieve has been achieved and now no
more turbines
should be should be said and i hope at
some point we're able to get support
from the committee for that uh
recommendation i want to conclude uh my
my um
the time and use this round of questions
to to uh speak to the ukrainian
ambassador thank you for your testimony
today
and all of us have been
um heartbroken to see the atrocities
being committed against the ukrainian
people and also inspired by the heroic
courage of ukrainians i did want to
mention uh and pay tribute to emil
antoine roy serwa who's a canadian
citizen who volunteered to go fight
alongside ukrainians and was killed in
action of course he joins many uh
ukrainian nationals uh and heroes who
have died in this war
but i wanted to mention him as a
canadian citizen who who volunteered to
join that effort
ambassador
there's been a lot of discussion about
the alliance and about the need to have
unity within the alliance what bothers
me about that discourse of course is
that um
the most important thing for the
alliance in terms of being united is
being united behind ukraine and
there's such an emphasis seems to be
being put on canada and germany being
united in their position but that
position is at odds with the most
important ally in this equation which is
ukraine and i suspect as well that there
are many other uh nations in central and
eastern europe uh who have the same
concerns about this policy of turbine
export uh that that i do
um so ambassador i wonder if you can
speak to discussions you've had with
other members of the the broader
alliance of democratic nations how they
perceive the energy security questions
uh what the position of other eu members
for example uh other than germany might
be with respect to turbine export and uh
and how the alliance is divided in light
of the fact that ukraine has not been
listened to in the case of the the
turbine issue
thank you and
it's do really not an easy and rather
complicated issue about the energy
security in europe and one because of
one big elephant in the room which is
russian gas problem
unfortunately this elephant was growing
for the decades
and
hurting
buying
bargaining a lot of countries for the
different ways
and
since the war started they were we
already have
been seeing several attempts for russia
to blackmail europe and the first cause
was the russian decision to for the
countries to pay for russian gas in
rubles
we see many countries and many european
companies who opposed to pay in rubles
and this was the first move russia cut
the gas to these countries
but they already found the way on how to
find the alternatives
there was another big push
unfortunately for those countries who
accepted to pay in rubles and followed
russia's blackmailing they turned out
the in the situation where now they
have almost zero gas flow
and this is the two lessons which is
important i think for everybody now to
learn
that any appeasement of putin's energy
blackmailing
can be successful
the second important thing that russia
itself already sanctioned for example a
big polish route that could be also the
alternative one to nordstrom one we had
um
a story with another pipeline and
pipelines are the
best examples of this putin's policy of
influencing
russia
influencing of russia to the european
policy this was the story of the north
stream two pipeline
we as ukraine and many eastern european
countries for years has been advocating
that this is a purely political project
that has no crowns
a year ago the sanctions from the north
stream 2 was waived but then the
sanctions
was input back
in february this year and we do value
and we do understand that after many
lessons we all know on the same page
that nordstrom 2 has been a political
project and now it is blocked
but russia is still rising this new
question so this is important
one more time to not to allow to make
the mistakes
and not to appease putin and for many
countries of the europe especially for
those 12 who already
face the full cap cut of russian gas
they are finding the alternatives
everybody in europe is finding the
alternatives and
we as ukraine also finding uh
since 2014
thank you ambassador my apologies uh mr
do you have the floor for five minutes
thank you mr chair uh first off i'd like
to thank all the ambassadors for taking
the time to join us here today
i also want to take the time to commend
germany and of course the eu for the
transition to clean energy and of course
for your solidarity in standing
alongside so many allies with ukraine as
as we
continue to to impose uh sanctions and
stand alongside our allies to to support
ukraine in this very difficult time uh
ambassador gabriel as you as you know
from our previous conversations uh we
spoke about uh how canada can help
in in terms of uh
delivering clean energy uh to
the european union of course to our
allies uh
i want to hear more about um the
situation uh with uh coal-fired plants
in europe right now
uh we we do know it's going to be
a tough winter ahead and something that
i know you're looking into
also i want to ask if you can elaborate
on the short and medium term issues
facing the eu
should russia
shut off its gas supplies
thank you
for this question
indeed
indeed
the european union is actually preparing
for the potential possible
further disruptions
from russian side of energy supplies
uh to this end uh as i said i already
mentioned that
we have a plan uh to uh
to
phase out our dependency on russian
energy sources all together
this plan is called repower eu
is actually envisages to uh the
diversification of our energy supplies
accelerating deployment of renewable
energy sources which we have been doing
at a great speed
and we are also
strengthening our energy efficiency and
energy
uh
saving
a big part of this uh this plan at this
point a very uh you know immediate uh
immediate effect uh we we've decided to
uh in solidarity uh to reduce 15 percent
of uh our gas consumption demand by 15
in solidarity with one another within
the uh
the european union among member states
uh but also in solidarity of course with
ukraine
so
we are looking for alternative and the
more secure supplies from reliable
reliable partners
such as canada while fast forwarding
the green transition and
we've been working very closely
and intensely on finding
these
avenues through which we can cooperate
with canada uh to um
to find uh uh concrete and viable areas
for our cooperation
and you know to identify the needs of
the eu or match the needs
with the uh
capacity of canada to identify uh the
challenges uh to uh to actually uh also
come up with a plan and how to proceed
along this la this
uh line and um of course the
conversation on energy cooperation
is ongoing uh including through the eu
canada high high-level energy dialogue
and there are options for mid to
long-term energy cooperation
on the table
thank you for that your excellency uh mr
how much time do i have left
yep i can't hear you
sorry i think we're down to about the
last 10 seconds so oh okay
i'll wrap it up nope thank you so much
ambassador i appreciate it
uh yes uh miss personal two and a half
minutes
thank you mr chair my question will be
for the ambassador of the european union
ms cabridge
you
made sure to signal in your opening
remarks that the eu was careful about
not imposing sanctions that would risk
putting in danger the
energy supply to eu member states
but when you saw canada introduce its
regime of sanctions
and knowing that the maintenance of
turbines was envisaged
did you warn the canadian government
about what could happen
we are not hearing your
ambassador mr bergeron
thank you for your question
so uh
actually as i explained in my opening
remarks that you referred to
the
repatriation of turbines is not uh in
contravention of the eu sanction regime
because the
goods and technology linked to transport
of natural gas
is not affected by eu sanctions
and neither is neither is nordstrom 1
affected by these sanctions
so this is certainly something that
i think
answers your question
yes but my question
was more
geared towards the following given that
canada's sanctions
were running the risk of affecting
turbines did you
warn canada
at the outset about the situation rather
than finding ourselves in a situation
where we have to manage this unfortunate
outcome
[Music]
uh not that i am aware of uh i am also
not i would also uh
venture to say uh that this would not be
something
that would be in um
a prerogative of the eu
okay since um
we are seeing that this was only a
pretext from putin's side and the
european commission declared that the
return of the turbine takes away this
pretext
why maintain this authorization mr
bergeron i'm sorry we're at uh
two two and a half minutes um
perhaps you could submit your question
in writing to the clerk and get an
answer that way
miss mcpherson you have the floor
maybe madame gabriel
could
respond in writing to the members of
this committee
yes is that acceptable
yeah thank you uh mr first send you the
floor for two and a half minutes and
that will wrap up
uh our witness the witness portion of
the meeting thank you very much and
thank you mr chair again thank you to
the ambassadors for being here i guess
what i will end with today is just you
know ultimately what has happened with
result with the result of this waiver is
that that we still have no
no energy supply that is necessary going
to germany we are still in the exact
same situation unfortunately we just
have a undermined sanction regime
but we do still want to ensure that
germany has the the support that they
require to get through the winter and to
manage their energy crisis and so i
would ask ambassador sparvasser if she
could please comment on what canada
could do more to help germany right now
um to to help in the short term i think
is is really what we're looking for
those solutions for
thank you so much uh miss mccroson um
the
canadian
side is helping by
backfilling as much as possible into
also the
u.s effort to provide germany with more
lng we have been receiving from a lot of
our allies
norway netherlands us and others
quite a bit more lng we've been
importing it we're building up lng ports
very fast in the medium term in the long
term canada can be a very important
supplier for our energy security and
canada can be one of the countries that
allows us to pursue our two goals become
independent of russian energy and to
fight climate change and to become
carbon neutral and we see canada as a
prime partner working as a transitional
energy maybe on lng but mostly working
on hydrogen and we are actively right
now pursuing talks with government with
provincial government with companies
this is a
very big target for us as soon as
possible
thank you very much ambassador and i'd
like to end with um ambassador kovalev
ambassador what would what would you
like to see canada do how can canada
support ukraine more at this time
i'd like to give you the final word for
the for this session
thank you and giving this opportunity i
would like to thank you everybody for
devoting your time for this particular
matter to the canadian government for
the steadfast support
for canadians who are helping ukraine
standing with ukraine and helping those
ukrainians who came to canada fleeing
the war it's very important and the war
is going on and it's very important for
all of us government of canada eu
government of
germany and other allies
to continue the support because
we need to win this war not only for us
as the country but all uh but also for
everybody for us as being in democracy
we do value the the support of all our
partners and we do
fighting hard
uh on the battlefield and
we do count on for the support for the
standing with ukraine until our victory
thank you for standing with us
thank you
uh thank you ambassador and um i i can't
say in my brief time as a member of
parliament since 2019 i've never seen
parliament so unified
and steadfast on any issue
uh than this and
our hearts and minds are certainly with
you and
um as the uh
uh one of the ambassadors said
earlier i'm sorry i can't recall which
one um
this is a
debate among
very good friends and uh
i think that's the spirit in which this
meeting was conducted and i want to
thank you all very much for answering
our questions and your patience
with our system in terms of how we time
our the allocation of rounds i know it's
a little annoying from time to time
so with that
i think we can release our witnesses
and again thank you very very much for
for being here
now
i see a hand up
mr genus
yeah mr mr chair i i was going to just
suggest we have a quick conversation
about when we're going to be next
because we had um
we had talked about a number of
different witness panels we wanted to
hear on this subject
um
i think maybe rather than having a a
stand-alone meeting again to discuss
committee business it might be good to
just uh exchange for
five minutes to figure out sure chair
i'm going to say a point of order if i
can interject please sure um
yes but chair uh we've gone past uh
we're now 5 18 we've gone past the the
five o'clock time uh we asked for 15
minutes of extra time it was unanimous
consent we went over uh i i moved to
that we just adjourned the movie the the
meeting now please yeah just on that
point of order mr chair you can't move a
motion when you don't have the floor so
um i mean he the point of order i mean
you're allowed to raise a point of order
but you can't move a motion point of
order
i guess i'm not
i'm not i'm not trying to move any
motions or anything colleagues i just
think it it's the point of discussion
here when when do
colleagues think we should meet next and
um
i mean i think we we had committed to
working to try to get to the bottom of
this issue and
um
i mean if if members prefer we can we
can schedule another meeting for
committee business i suppose but
um
but i i think it makes sense for us to
uh just try to identify when we're going
to meet and meet next to proceed with
this work
i'm not sure if that's a point to order
but
it's not a point of order i'm not
running a point of order i
put my hand up to speak okay um
well i guess i just is there
an appetite right now for the committee
to discuss scheduling uh our next
meeting
i see one head nodding in the negative
okay that's
let's take a little straw poll here
allie you don't get to vote
so thumbs up for yes to a discussion
right now about
schedule
we're not going to have something you
probably need unanimous consent over yes
so um i i guess we're going to have to
adjourn
mr trump i don't know if that's the case
i mean if the committee the committee
should only adjourn uh based on majority
consent as the principle so um i see
that
uh it seems conservative in the ndp want
to have this discussion i'm not sure
where mr bergeron is at he would be the
deciding vote but
chair did you not just adjourn the
meeting
i said i guess we should adjourn i
didn't say we are adjourned in in in in
practice the the the principle is that
it's it's uh consent of the majority of
the committee is the standard for
adjournment
point of order on on that i just want to
say that uh having
chaired a number of committees over the
years um it requires the announcement
consent to adjourn a meeting so as long
as members want to talk
you can talk
um and i would also just say that that
talking about the agenda of the
committee
based upon what we just heard is also in
order because it is relevant to the
business at hand
um mr clerk uh just some clarification
uh
um on this um
what what are the rules around uh
adjourning um
we need a majority to adjourn the
committee
so it's not unanimous no as mr bazan
said
because i have seen situations where
someone moves adjournments and then
there's votes and it's a delatory motion
okay
mr may i order
a
motion to adjourn the reading please
sorry i i i had the floor uh mr chair so
maybe just to make this simple i didn't
he didn't acknowledge he hadn't he
so i made a point of where i've made a
motion and that's happened
yeah so chair look i'll just make this
simple um it's up to the majority of the
committee decide how they proceed uh i
will i will move a motion that we have
now a 10 minute discussion about the
foregoing business of the committee so
i'll move that motion
um and i suggest we vote on it and if
there's a desire to have that 10 minute
discussion we'll have the 10-minute
discussion
okay there's a motion on the floor is
that a
any uh discussion or debate on the
motion
i see
i don't see anyone's hand up so i guess
we'll go to a vote
mr clerk could you call the vote please
[Music]
mr sorbara
no
mr sidhu
no
mr sarai
no
mr zuberi
abstain
mr lippert
uh no
sorry
i'm sorry
in favor
mr bazan
mr bergeron
so it's a thai vote we have four years
four nays
um
so as i understand that i have the
deciding votes i'll uh vote yay
so um
uh the meeting is will continue now for
10 minutes and we will
discuss
anyone want to start
my head is raised chair if you oh sure
sorry mr janice you uh have the floor
thank you uh thank you sure so um i i
would just propose the following uh that
um
that we schedule ukrainian canadian
congress uh to provide an additional
hour of testimony
uh that we um that we gather uh
witnesses from uh parties as per the
um as per the original motion
uh and that we schedule additional
meetings on this issue next week and the
week after
in order to continue
the work that has been
begun on this urgent issue
and that
the
the chair be asked to schedule witnesses
uh that are proposed by the various
parties uh in in rough proportion to uh
to those parties and if necessary in
consultation with the vice chairs as per
as per the standard practice but that we
that we continue to hold hearings on
this subject uh next week and the week
after in order to get get to the bottom
of this and that as part of that uh we
hear from the ukrainian canadian
congress for an additional hour so
that's what what i would propose
generally speaking
my name
is chair miss ben diane is on the list
dan you have the floor
i'm sorry mr chair i did not mean to
interrupt in the order is there someone
who needs to go before me
uh mr bergeron has his hands up
doing this virtually mr bergeron
thank you mr chair
first of all
i find the motion
[Music]
presented by mr genus extremely
uh confusing so i wouldn't have the idea
i i wouldn't dare
venture on it that there seem to be many
elements in the motion
first to bring the
ucc back
i
we can't do
uh something
we can't do directly indirectly either
so i i'm i'm not against the idea of
inviting the canadian
ukrainian canadian congress
and i'm saying this again this is not
the first time i've said this in
committee before this is not the manner
of imposing
a witness to the committee we have
ways of working that goes through the
subcommittee for instance or a
an informal meeting of the committee
where we discuss witnesses we send
witness lists to the clerk
simply to have this kind of discussion
so i am announcing my interest right
away i will
vote when we have this discussion in
favor of uh inviting ucc back but i
don't think that this is the right
moment right now today to do this
because we have to be able to discuss
the entirety of witnesses and
not just pick and choose so i will vote
against the motion even though it is a
bit confusing and it will be only for
this reason that i'm voting against
before i get to mr janice
miss bandai to do did you want the floor
we
maximized yes mr chair
i am happy to have heard my colleague mr
bergeron because i am
i fully agree with him
uh maybe we can envisage a procedure a
normal procedure whereby
we can discuss
um
these issues but also establish
um
deadlines
for members of the committee to propose
other witnesses i'm very open to the
idea of inviting
the
ukrainian canadian congress back
and we we heard them today of course and
there are many other witnesses which
would be who would be interested in
coming in to discuss these issues and
committee with us so i don't really
understand why we are insisting
only on this particular witness normally
our panels have multiple witnesses
so
as
the chair you mentioned that we had 10
minutes for this discussion and i'm
looking at the time and
it's already 5 30 almost
um i don't know
if this will
result in anything concrete in the
upcoming meetings maybe we would need to
schedule another discussion some some
other time
mr chair i
think i still have the floor
i will
end
by proposing that to the committee be
adjourned now
is that a motion
yes it's a motion to adjourn
okay um it's a dilatory motion so mr
clerk will you please call the vote
eminem ben dianne
mr zobara
we
mr sidhu yes mr sarai
yes mr zuberi
yes mr lippert
uh
against
uh mr bezan
mr genuis
sorry against
mr bergeron
for four
no
so we have six yays four nades
so the
motion passes the meeting is adjourned
thank you everyone